Bobby fer played Bishop to B4 and again
he has to continue to March down the
it's a force move he has no other
options and Bobby Fischer now plays
Bishop to B3 forced move to C1 now he
brings his Knight back into the action
he's now forced again to come to B1 and
King comes back to
C1 then The Rook comes to C2 in his
Checkmate so he really showed um even
sacrificing his Queen he knew that he
could really use all of his minor pieces
you know
cohesively and dominate the game one
fantastic Sacrifice from Bobby Fischer
fantastic game played by a 13-year-old I
don't even know how you play chess at 13
like that but hope you guys enjoyed this
game it is the game of the century
because it was so fantastic